there's currently a ton of hype over
apple's brand new m2 macbooks and that's
why we just ordered four of the macbook
pros for our in-depth testing and
comparison videos but we're already
seeing reports about apple's higher end
m2 pro and m2 max macbook pros going
into production very soon and based on
all of my research i have a pretty good
feeling that these 14 and 16 inch
macbook pros are gonna be a lot more
powerful than everybody's expecting so
in this video i'm gonna explain why i'm
now fully convinced that apple's m2 pro
and max chips will actually be built on
tsmc's brand new three nanometer process
snow technology contrary to the
mainstream belief that they'll be based
on the m2 chips 2nd gen 5 nanometer node
and yes i know that sounds crazy because
it's the complete opposite of what apple
did with their m1 chips where the entire
lineup was based on the same first
generation 5 nanometer node but trust me
by the end of this video i think you'll
be convinced as well so let's get
started first off i want to provide some
evidence from multiple sources that
tsmc's 3 nanometer chip technology
should be ready in time for the launch
of apple's m2 pro and m2 max macbook
pros back in march mark german reported
that apple will likely not launch the
new 14 and 16 inch macbook pro models
until 2020
and just a couple of weeks ago he gave
us an update saying that it could be the
end of this year or early next year now
in my opinion i think early 2023
specifically at a spring event makes the
most sense for the launch of these
macbook pros and that's because i fully
believe apple's fall events will be
consumed by the release of the
redesigned m2 mac mini the m2 ipad pros
and potentially even the new mac pro so
to me it makes the most sense for the
new macbook pros to get revealed in the
spring of next year because i fully
believe that apple is switching to an 18
month or one and a half year timeline
for major mac updates and i'm confident
in this because apple revealed their m2
chip around 18 months after the original
m1 in november of 2020 and we already
have many rumors from multiple sources
that the m3 chip is going to be revealed
at the end of 2023 which will also be
around 18 months after the launch of the
m2 hence an 18-month timeline and as we
know the m1 pro and m1 max chips were
revealed in november of 2021 and 18
months after that lands perfectly in the
spring of next year but moving on to the
actual chip side of things back in april
mark grumman reported that there's
already evidence of apple internally
testing the new m2 pro and max chips
with up to 12 cpu cores and 38 gpu cores
and that actually confirms a report from
995 mac in march claiming that apple's
working on two mac minis one with an m2
chip for launch later this year and
another with an m2 pro chip with a 12
core cpu exactly what mark german
reported but the biggest bombshell leak
came from jeff poo just a couple of
weeks ago claiming that tsmc will be
starting mass production of new three
nanometer m2 pro chips later this year
yes he actually said three nanometer
chips in mass production this year which
would be perfect for a spring 2023
launch and at first i had trouble
believing him because the entire m1
family of chips was based on the same
first gen five nanometer process node so
why in the world would apple build half
of the m2 family of chips on a three
nanometer node and the regular m2s on
five nanometer well i came up with four
pretty good reasons for apple to do this
first of all if the m2 pro and max chips
are based on the same five nanometer
node that the m2 chip is based on then
the performance might be quite
disappointing because the ipc
improvements are pretty minimal on the
m2 with most of the gains coming from
the extra gpu course and now for the
second reason tsmc's three nanometer
technology is a major breakthrough as
i'm gonna show you guys in just a minute
which means that it's also gonna be
quite expensive and the key point is
that whenever a breakthrough chip node
gets released like a three nanometer die
the yields on those dies are pretty low
since the technology to make them is
brand new so it actually makes the most
sense to debut a new process node on a
product that doesn't sell in massive
volumes making a three nanometer launch
perfect for apple's higher end and more
expensive macbook pros especially since
that's the target market that actually
cares about having the highest
performance which a new three nanometer
process would give so because of that i
came up with a very interesting theory
what if apple intentionally wanted to
split up their m2 family of chips
between five nanometer and three
nanometer base process nodes and why
would they do this well because apple
knows that their lower end macs like the
m1 macbook air and base m1 macbook pro
are the best selling laptops in the
world and if these chips were based on
three nanometer tech they literally
would not have enough yield left over
for their higher end m2 pro and max
chips so by building their brand new
basic m2 chip on the already existing
and mature five nanometer process and
giving that to their highest and highest
volume products like the new m2 macbook
air the base macbook pro likely the
upcoming mac mini and the future ipad
pro and ipad air models they would be
ensuring that their higher end macbook
pros have as many brand new three
nanometer chips as they need to account
for the low initial yields and then
later in 2023 they could finally bring
three nanometer to the lower end max
when the yields have finally improved
and from a design standpoint apple has
always started their chip designs with
their iphone chips and scaled them up to
their larger ipad chips but now that the
apple silicon mac transition is about to
complete what if apple switches to doing
everything in reverse what if they start
their chip design with the m2 max die
built on the brand new 3 nanometer node
and then they simply combine two of
those dies to create the m2 ultra chip
or four of them to create the m2 extreme
destined for the mac pro while at the
same time cutting the m2 max in half to
create the m2 pro chip just like they
did with the m1 pro and then on the flip
side they can take the m2 max die and
scale it down to create the future m3
chip because i believe it's easier to
scale down than it is to scale up
and then they can take those same cores
from the m2 max and scale them down
further for the new a17 chip design
going into the iphone so you basically
have an entire array of chips based
entirely on the single m2 max die
requiring the least amount of r d
possible and saving apple cash and if
you're not convinced yet that the m2 pro
and max dies will be built on three
nanometer here is the nail in the coffin
if apple's chips are truly on a 1.5 year
timeline and apple chose to go with five
nanometer again for the m2 pro and max
chips then these high-end chips wouldn't
be built on three nanometer until the
fall of 2024
which is honestly way too long and i'm
gonna prove it to you tsmc just had
their technology symposium event for
2022 where they revealed their updated
roadmap for their chip nodes and guess
what their brand new 3 nanometer n3 node
is in their
2022 timeline with tsmc confirming that
m3 is on track to start high volume
manufacturing in the second half of this
year with actual chips set to get
delivered to real customers in early
2023 perfectly fitting the 18-month
timeline for when the m2 pro and m2 max
macbook pros should get released but
wait they added a disclaimer this
technology is mostly aimed at early
adopters like apple who can invest in
leading-edge designs and would benefit
from the performance power and area
advantages offered by leading edge notes
so why in the world would apple not
adopt three nanometer for their m2 pro
and max chips if three nanometer is
actually going to be ready right in time
for launch do you really believe they
would let their competitors adopt three
nanometer first while they wait another
18 months until late 2024 for the m3 pro
and max chips well i don't especially
since there are rumors that intel is
delaying their meteor lake chips until
the third or fourth quarter of 2023 the
same chips that are supposed to
partially utilize tsmc's new three
nanometer process node and that intel
delay means more three nanometer chip
yields for apple's m2 pro and max chips
coming in early 2023 so hopefully all of
that was enough to convince you that
apple's new chips will be based on
tsmc's three nanometer node but now
let's finish off with why this is going
to be a massive deal for this new
high-end macbook pros but first i want
to give a huge shout out to our brand
new m2 cubed chip design that you can
find in our merch shelf right below this
video and make sure to use the coupon
code m2 chip to save 20
on all of our merch speaking of n3 tsmc
expects a 25 to 30 reduction in power
usage with three nanometer compared to
five nanometer which is massive allowing
the chips to run a lot cooler and save
battery life and on the flip side they
expect 10 to 15 more performance and
that's not even counting apple's own
upgrades that they can make like
redesigning the actual cores increasing
caches adding in faster ram and adding
in more cores but by far the biggest
benefit is the brand new n3 finflex
hybrid technology that tsmc just
announced which for the first time ever
allows them to split their n3 nodes into
three different options one with three
two fins for maximum performance one
with two two fins for a good balance
between performance power efficiency and
density and then a 2 1 fin for ultra
power efficiency with the lowest power
consumption and highest density and the
best part is that apple will be able to
combine those three varieties of n3 onto
the same die for the first time ever
which could drastically improve
performance and efficiency since the
current n5 node is set to too thin
across the entire die with no fine
tuning allowed so there you guys go
that's why i think the new m2 pro and
max chips are gonna be based on tsmc's
three nanometer process node which is
gonna make them absolutely insane and if
you disagree with me go ahead and let me
know down in the comment section below
but if you enjoyed the video click the
circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one and check out one
of those two right there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
one
[Music]